- It's gonna be so easy, and
I'm gonna look like an idiot.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] You have a shot of whiskey,
and two empty shot glasses.
Can you make a bridge
between the empty glasses
that supports the shot of whiskey?
If you can, you get 20 bucks.
If you can't, you get the shot of whiskey.
- What? (laughing)
- In a previous life, I like to think
I could have been an architect.
- Basically what I'm trying to figure out
is how to make this taut enough.
- This is gonna go horribly wrong.
- (snapping) Let's do this,
so I have to make a bridge.
- I'm assuming there's
some folding involved.
- I'm just gonna take you out
of the equation right now.
- Okay, that's not gonna work.
- I'm gonna spill everywhere!
- I can't hold it?
I can't touch it?
- Are you sure you're not
leaving out some tools?
Like some tooth picks?
- (laughing) This is going really well.
- Why do I always do this to myself?
I come here and get frustrated,
time and time again.
- I wonder if it's like some sort of V.
- If I pay you this $20,
can I get a hint? (laughing)
- Okay, is there a longer 20?
Is this a shorter 20?
- But if I try to like...
Really crinkle it up.
That still is not gonna work.
- What if I just rip
this $20 bill in half?
- Oh my god, this is it.
No, fuck.
- Come on.
I can do this, where is a
pep talk when I need it?
- I don't. (laughing)
I wanna do this so badly
without you telling me.
(sighing)
- Let's go back to square one, no.
- (singing) I give up.
- I give up, I give up.
- Show me.
- [Camera Man] Give up!
(laughing)
- Alright.
- [Narrator] Take the $20
bill and start folding
long ways on alternating sides,
until the bill resembles an accordion.
Rest the folded bill on
top of the empty glasses.
Place the full shot of
whiskey in the middle.
Collect your money.
- Are you gonna fold it up?
- I did that.
- Are you kidding me?
- I'm annoyed.
- What?
- Come on.
- But like, that's stupid,
and I'm gonna sip this.
- Clink, ew I don't wanna do this.
Oh my god, I already regret it.
- Alright.
I have to go get back to work. (laughing)
- Pretty good. (laughing)